tomorrow's Halloween
[Applause]
[Music]
pretty scary huh Andy yeah that was
spooktacular
fool
you got your costumes of a pict I mean
it's come on we're 24 hours out now
folks you gotta get ready I just have to
say ladies I'm I'm sorry if you're we're
planning on going as sexy Conan it's
taken
[Applause]
I'm also [ __ ] Conan I can go either
way
that sexy Conan after one glass of wine
yeah half a glass okay
rip take a look at these what am I
talking about I don't know I don't know
you know what's interesting things are a
little different there's a new tradition
this Halloween this is true if you see a
blue pumpkin that means the house is
handing out allergy free treats that's
true yeah yeah you see a blue pumpkin
yeah of course
if you see a blue pumpkin it could also
mean that the house is using last year's
pumpkin this exciting news yesterday was
the internet's 45th birthday
that's right 45 years ago today someone
downloaded porn onto a Commodore 64 took
seven hours to download I like that the
internet was probably really around for
about what five hours before they
started using oh absolutely absolutely
started printing out nudes on dot-matrix
yeah what else is going on Kim
Kardashian is in the news Kim Kardashian
said she might let her daughter North
design clothes for her fashion line yeah
she said I think North is up for it cuz
she already created a bib that says get
me the hell out of here
he's freed me from these people Cosmo
magazine you read Cosmo magazine I do
ever
Cosmo magazine is encouraging female
students in North Carolina to vote by
offering a party bus to the polls that
includes shirtless male models yeah the
female students are signing up in droves
to pull the lever and also to vote
[Applause]
you